[Music]
imagine imagine that you're seeing
things that aren't there
and you're confused about time and place
and you quickly forget things that
happen to you you're hallucinating
you're delirious
you're suffering from amnesia if you
were to walk into a doctor's office with
any of these symptoms you'd be declared
psychopathic maybe even placed in an
institution and yet all of us were in
this state 12 hours ago we were sleeping
and that's the seeming paradox of sleep
this state that was selected by Nature
over the course of 3.6 million years and
it makes no sense think about from an
evolutionary perspective when you're
sleeping you're not finding food
you're clearly now reproduce not even
you're not even fending for yourself
you're totally vulnerable on any of
these grounds sleep should have been
strongly selected against yet here we
are three and a half million years later
spending a third of our lives in this
state of flagrant psychosis if sleep
doesn't serve some truly vital function
then it's the biggest mistake the
evolutionary process ever made we now
know that sleep does have many vital
functions from cementing learning and
consolidating memory to regulating
emotion and fostering the association of
disparate experiences and we also know
that the vast majority of us need
between seven to nine hours of sleep per
night to function properly so why do we
have such a hard time getting the amount
of sleep our brain so crave because we
live in a culture that prices sleep
machismo and we perpetuate a series of
myths so let's talk about a couple of
them so first myth you might say I can
go with five or six hours of sleep ER
and I didn't feel just fine and you'd be
partially right there are some people
that have a rare genetic mutation that
allows them to get by with five hours or
less of sleep each night with
showing any signs of impairment however
according to dr. Thomas Ruth from the
Henry Ford Hospital in Detroit the
proportion of the population for which
this is the case rounded to the nearest
whole number is zero it's negligible for
the rest of us insufficient sleep can
have serious consequences let me tell
you about an experiment dr. David
dentist the University of Pennsylvania
took two groups of people one of whom
was sleep deprived the other of whom was
drunk drunk too the legal driving limit
so pointer weight percent of Plaut
alcohol and he gave these both of these
groups a concentration test to assess
cognitive performance and what he found
was that after just 19 hours of being
awake 19 hours the sleep deprived group
was as cognitively impaired as the group
that was legally drunk so think about
what that means imagine you wake up on a
Friday at 7 a.m. and you go to work and
you spend your day at work then maybe
you go out on the evening on a date or
with friends typical Friday and even if
you drink no alcohol whatsoever by the
time you're driving back home at 2:00 in
the morning you're essentially a drunk
driver but you might say wait you know I
really do get five or six hours of sleep
per night in fact I just got six hours
of sleep over the past few nights and I
feel great I feel fantastic am i
delusional and the answer is yes
yes you are dr. dangers experiment had a
twist
and when he asked the sleep-deprived
group how cognitively impaired they felt
they significantly underestimated their
degree of disability in fact their
self-assessment was a terrible miserable
predictor of just how bad they performed
another major problem tied to this is
something called baseline resetting and
it's been shown that after months or
years of chronic sleep deprivation
people actually acclimate to their
impaired performance and reduced energy
levels never even realizing that they're
failing to maximize the potential of
mind and body
epidemiological studies suggest that
millions of people spend years of their
lives living like this so bottom line is
we don't know how sleep-deprived we are
when we're sleep-deprived and that's the
scariest part of it all now 1/2 a second
myth we've all probably said at some
point in our lives you know I'll just
sleep it off over the weekend and the
research shows that just isn't the case
or brains are incapable of that so back
to doctor didn't just study after the
initial test he took those
sleep-deprived group and gave them three
full recovery nights so three full
nights of sleep then tested them again
what do you think happened the second
time around turns out that even after
3/4 recovery night's performance still
did not return to the original baseline
levels sleep just doesn't work like that
fact we now know that lack of sleep
builds up and compounds over time and
research even links it to some of the
most feared diseases in the developed
world one of them is Alzheimer's
Alzheimer's is triggered by a metabolic
toxin called beta-amyloid which builds
up naturally in our brains over the
course of the day and sleep offers a
cleansing mechanism and so the last
sleep you're having across your lifespan
though more of that toxic protein is
building up night after night year after
year so when sufficient sleep is now
considered one of the most significant
lifestyle factors determining whether or
not you'll develop the disease
and for that reason doctor Walker from
Berkeley goes as far as to call
wakefulness a state of low-level brain
damage whereas sleep offers a repertory
function okay so sleep matters I hope
you'll agree with me on that so what's
the upshot what can we do to help combat
sleep machismo and address the sleepless
epidemic so first off in an individual
level there's a ton of research and
literature out there on on insomnia and
how to improve your sleep so I won't
delve too much into it all I'll say is
that by far the best thing you can do
for your sleep is simply give yourself
an eight-hour window no it takes a
meaningful lifestyle change but it's
totally worth it on the business level
despite what we now know about sleep
sleep machismo remains pervasive in fact
lack of sleep is often even boasted as a
badge of honor as an example in my
former job as a consultant one of the
lead partners in the firm loved to have
sleep as one of his work life balance
kpi's and his aspirational metric to
gates almost how much sleep he was
getting was having no less than four and
a half hours of sleep per night on
average four and a half hours and that
was the aspiration
of course that mindset trickle down to
the rest of the team and the broader
firmament reinforce the stigmatization
of sleep so from those overnight red-eye
flights to the always on expectation and
the indefinite work schedules that often
drag beyond midnight I believe that
sleep merits a radical rethink of
policies and priorities in the business
world because awareness drives action
and change has to come from the top
we've all heard the old maxim you can
sleep when you're dead
let me tell you that is mortally unwise
advice we now know that the shorter you
sleep the shorter you live and the
quality of that now shorter life will be
much worse sleep is not a paradox it is
not a luxury research for those of us
without busy lives it is a biological
necessity and it is critical I sincerely
hope that you'll reflect on some of
these learnings and if you don't please
just sleep on it
[Applause]
[Music]